meine augen ich gehe man die fans kam
dass es unglaublich unglaublich was
dieser zu den waffen heftig das ist was
ist zu den waffen für eine tiefe
zuschauer und herzlich willkommen zurück
bleiben minecraft varro mit dem mit dem
mittel mit dem regen
alles ist nass spritzte hier auch direkt
wieder so dann ja ja wir sollten wir
sollten einfach anfangen uns jetzt
gleich mal spitzhacken zu machen und so
was oder
wir sollten wir uns weil wir ja ich habe
hier so einen tollen table den setzt
jetzt einfach mal hin
okay okay jetzt natürlich stark was
jetzt gemacht
also ich mach einfach mal eine
spitzhacke ich war auch schon ein ich
bin ich bin schon dran du musst wieder
direkt in das in das gefühl rein kommen
ja auch wenn jetzt auch einem auch wenn
auch wenn das hier gerade spannend wird
conny das ist dass ich entspannt ja
stein spitzhacke machen also kurz zur
erwähnung ist es gerade neben uns
niemand auf dem server das heißt es sind
allein und kann uns ein bisschen
entspannen uns auf historischen abbau
konzentrieren
ich hab mir gerade als alle welt gemacht
hat ich mache erst mal ein schwert
glaube ich wir wollen übrigens jetzt
diese folge mal so ein bisschen
durchziehen also ich gucke erstmal meine
lampe an stadt und die festgäste gucken
wir wollen jetzt nicht so sagen der
kunden jetzt müssen sondern wir wollen
schon farben weil es ich würd sagen
früher oder später auf seinem bett mit
strauß kommen weil in der ersten folge
direkt schon fünf leute gestorben sind
jetzt wird das natürlich nicht so sein
dass jetzt in jeder folge fünf leute
sterben bei irgendwem weil man natürlich
so nicht aus dem weg geht aber es nimmt
die jeder zu den gleichen zeiten auch
sage ich mal so es ist jetzt nicht so
dass wir sagen okay 15 uhr pflicht
aufnahme obwohl das eventuell ihre
lieder sollten sollten wir vielleicht
gleich mal da hinten zu dieser zu dieser
schlucht gehen vielleicht kommen
leichter an ärzten irgendwie gleich
machen was man von ihm ja ja der cdu
führt dann können wir wollten eben da
hinten
tiere eben töten das manchmal sind also
da wollte ich gerade gut ich bleibe hier
wie immer einen schritt voraus
das ist traurig und zwar weh tun hat
gekämpft und charakter sind ja schön
dass das das freut mich total
übrigens erst mal du musst was erklären
im intro das ganze sofort machen wie
hastig allerdings noch sagen wollte ist
erstmal schön houston krass rote augen
das liegt nicht daran bei instagram gibt
es davon noch ein viel heftigere bild
ich das liegt nicht daran dass ich
irgendwie das komplett verfügbare gras
auf dieser welt konsumiert habe sondern
das liegt ganz einfach daran dass ich
letzte nacht letzten tag den letzten
also bevor beim letzten schlaf war ich
720 stunden wach hab dann vier stunden
geschlafen bin jetzt seit ihm wieder
wach und das wiegt sie einfach meine
augen aus also ich bin komplett bei sinn
und ein bisschen also wie viele unter
die trader gesteuert und gestorben haben
genau vorgeschrieben haben viele sind
gestorben an diesem keller ja dass das
gz wie viele darüber geschrieben haben
dass wir die erste folge nicht überleben
und da dass ich normal sind still am
schlüssel hier wo bist du eigentlich bin
ich klatsche hühner ich weiß auch wir
müssen uns jetzt um ärzte kümmern auf
jeden fall ich genau weg gibt die das
kleine ligna sucht du irgendwelche
anderen ärzte die ärzte hier dieser
kohle ja klar ich laufe ich glaube
darüber dass würden polen
wer mir das ganze fleisch war langsam
raten sollen wir brauchen aber langsam
sondern kleine untergrund basis wäre ich
da für mich mich nervt auch der regen
nervt mich grad mega da macht mich ganz
ganz ganz thüringen das ist ja eine
gewisse spannung ist so eine
endzeitstimmung ja und gleichkommt kran
kräfte aus der dunkelheit mit wave und
guck mal ich bin jetzt einfach die unten
hin und dann mache ich hier entspannt
mehr ein deutlich mehr einreicht tot
bist du denn jetzt schon wieder geht aus
ich bin hier sag mal bist du bist nur
versiert das ist schrecklich nun dazu
dieser kurs ist du mich nein rechts
rechts rechts hier guck mal hier
da siehst du mich conny cornelia ich
konnte dir und dann brauche ich mich
jetzt einfach mal hier rein und gucken
nach irgendwelchen er zu uns herunter
bauen also ich glaub so auf ebene 13 bin
ich vergiftet klar ich bin vergiftet
conny i
vergiftet bist ja bin ich wirklich ich
habe nur durch das fleisch das er nicht
gebraten
da müssen wir uns auch mal gleich darum
kümmern dass wir fleisch da hatten wir
ja ich hab ja extra krone geholt weil
man wissen dass das so gut gemacht jetzt
erstmal gucken wir sind hier bei y wie
lange ich das nicht gemacht habe wir
müssten schon wieder ist schon wieder
weg gelaufen ja weil ich nein ich
brauche ich hier gerade rein wir sind
bei y 74 weiß wie lange ist ob es über
ihr guck mal hallo da du ja ich
vielleicht auch ein bisschen dass man
auf machen hier ja nochmal was direkt
den eingangs produktiv bonn
wir wollen gleich wieder ab super dass
wir müssen mehrere mehrere öfen machen
und dann uns beeilen gleich dies und das
warten wir mal kohle rein und genau
genauso so ist du hast das du warst
super danke ich bin ich bin so schön wir
uns nicht so eine basis reihen bauen
hier irgendwie an rand oder so ja ich
bin ja ich bin ja ich will wir brauchen
eisen
ja weil wir uns hier auch an den rand
dass wir das hier kommt doch mal jetzt
geht das argument ich gucke ich guck mal
hoch wie hier irgendwie also an rand so
dass hier hier gar nix merkel mal ein
paar fackeln das wäre vielleicht gar
keine so schlechte idee ganz ruhig ganz
wohl ganz ruhig die zweite folge glaube
ich habe noch gute chancen zu überleben
hier
wir müssen noch ungefähr neun minuten
durch da sollte man schon gesehen gesät
conny und ich habe echt hohe ansprüche
bei diesem projekt ihr ja ich ganz
einfach mal drunter hoffnung einfach
irgendwann eisen zu finden aber ich
apple was natürlich auch
notwendig für uns gerade ist wir hätten
halt gleich einen tieferen punkt gehen
müssen weil ich glaube ich jetzt hier
bis zu 13 vor das zaudern der ewigkeit
während alle anderen spieler vielleicht
hätte ich einfach in dieser schlucht da
unten mitte das gucken sollen ja dabei
sind hier so eine kleine bar sonst was
aber heißt das ich seit genau das ist
der grund genau jetzt bin ich jetzt bin
ich an erde angelangt das pflicht mit rd
aliens was tut er auf der höhe
versteh nicht der regen hat aufgehört
mit dem ich denn sagen weil ich sinnlos
dem das ist ja noch entspricht
die station wird aber leute wir kennen
keinen spaß also ich weiß gar nicht wie
video auf diesem ist ich weiß dass auch
nicht bei uns ist steht skill an der
obersten stellen spiele aber es war nur
ein skelett
okay okay von crafter tötet tötet
jetzt sehe du ich träume nicht nachher
sterblich alter das wäre das 2 3
das reicht das recht ein schwert das
reicht für für jeden für uns von eisen
fertiger die dort jetzt mal eingebaut
hier die gratis den luchs bei uns hier
direkt mal reisen kassiert krass ich bin
erst mal hoch ja ich komme zu dir
ich hab jetzt hat man hier eingebaut
dass irgend jemand hinkommt oder soja
raps crafter sagen achtung achtung
dieser bericht ist aber nicht bei uns in
der nähe oder das finde ein bisschen
unangenehm mattes
ich habe da mal so was wie wo sie
positive sind die kräftig tables hast du
irgendwo ich habe einen im inventar wir
sollten wir sollten übrigens steigen
brennen damit wir das so zu machen
können als hätten wir hier nie
aufgemacht
verstehst was ich meine also man sieht
zwar die namen aber dann ist das so ein
bisschen dubioser verstehst du wie du
was meinst du jetzt mal einfach hier
offen und wir können das hier können wir
brennen ja und dann wird das ja wieder
dienst ohne dann können wir den eingang
ab machen und sieht das so aus als du
schießt einfach mal mehr macht man
offenkundig komm mama mehr höfen ja klar
wir müssen ja wir uns ja fleisch braten
möglich schnell und alles und diese das
machen wir rufen kommen ja ja das recht
knapp aus so dass letztendlich noch mehr
gebrannt werden das ist auch so gut
jetzt dann hast du denn überhaupt nicht
axima dahin hier sind für eisenerze mach
dir mal komm komm lass ich lass ich mich
wohler kriegen du alter 5 1 ich dachte
derzeit 30 oder ja nie ich bin ich habe
erst die ader geöffnet man sollte nicht
immer so anspruchsvoll was ich auch
erstmal weiter du kannst du mehr machen
ich habe meine vier gebrachten fleischer
denn rausgenommen fackeln ich mache
jetzt auch einfach fackeln
ich hoffe ich mache mir gleich schon mal
was das erschwert wir müssen jemand muss
raus holz holen
neben pflanzen uns hier drinnen einfach
einbauen hast du erde ja neun stück
moment mit einer kurzen raum für einen
hausbaum bräuche kurzen raum für ein
schöner baum
das ist killer dass wir einfach so viel
spaß sind die unter der erde wurden und
einfach jaja untersuchten mit einem land
und schützen uns hat einfach gleich weg
dass sie schon kommen einfach so jeder
person zu schreiben so von rosen kaufen
wir wollen nur frieden mit allen und
sorge
ein alter schrank ja nicht schreiben wir
schreiben einfach jeder person wir sind
grad
wir sind ja gar nicht auf den server wir
sehen gar nicht drauf genau ich bin
irgendwo anders raus ich habe ich hab
schon geschafft mich jetzt zu verlauf
wollte ich noch ankündigen
wo bist du denn da bist du weg ja ich
gehe weiter runter und sucht zeugen bin
schon bei 50 von y
ich gebe ich gedenke das auch weiter zu
tun ich gehe immer weiter runter conny
und ich wollen uns hier in uns die
ressourcen raus platz ab die dünnen
wände diamanten finden wäre schon schön
wenn meine das wäre das war richtig dass
wir richtig richtig schnieke du und
jetzt also wir sind da nicht ein holz
hier gelassen
doch habe ich oder oder wie ich hatte
ich hatte nur und ich hab ich noch einen
holzblock oder so schmiedekunst du dich
habe ich ein richtiger richtiger fuchs
ihre jobs du bist ja deutschlands weit
frächter freitags nach joko
winterscheidt genau deswegen 22 ich
sagen wir brauchen drei holz sonst geht
hier gar nichts
dann geht auch ruhig mal raus du komm
doch mal das glaubt ihm alleine raus
conny online raus hat er müsse wohl noch
erzählt mir dass er dich nur töten
wollte
damit ich für ein bonus kriegt ja bei
mir entschuldigt hat mich dann an meinte
dann ich bin der der dich boxen wollte
einmal die so ok hallo hallo ja dann
ich hab schon ab schon wieder ein
bisschen eisen am stück hat ist gerade
erst aufgehört
nein das ist ja auch kaum gehen wir auf
dem server hört auf zu es an zu regnen
ich bin jetzt gleich bei 13 das heißt
ich bin dann auf diamanten höhe und kann
dann anfang mit so einer krassen taktik
durch die gegend zu graben wo meine
augen nenne ich gehe man ihr an die fans
kennen dass es unglaublich unglaublich
weit über dieser zu den waffen heftig
das ist was ist zu den waffen für eine
tiefe und time to strike bei mir ist auf
englisch
sorry ich kann kein englisch bonner
grundschule teilte strike wahrscheinlich
haben sie einen diamant schwert die sind
ich habe diamanten einschweißen keine
das grünzeug das ist doch was war das
noch mal mit ihrem red bull los ein ich
irgendwie so ein zeug ich kann mich mit
dem text päckchen und nicht so ganz aus
ich lasse es war oben vielleicht sind
auch diamanten
werd ich sehen sobald ein stück runter
geht aber da hab ich noch keinen baum
gepflanzt
das heißt das ist alles was du innerhalb
der letzten 10
ich musste mit einer wurden packs den
ganzen raum ausfüllen das dauert so
lange studieren kann aussteigen gemacht
weil ich doch kein holz habe dann hätten
wir vielleicht vorher holz farbenblind
open quali ja du hast auch holz aber du
bist ja woanders
ich hab' ich hab keine angst ich bin
jetzt aber jedenfalls mal auf 13 und
damit bin ich auf der höhe wo man wo man
wahrscheinlich diamanten kay pass auf
dass du nicht in lagerfelds das ist denn
das jemanden das ist leider
wahrscheinlich ob es dazu gegeben hätte
immer geknickt cadooz ja ja auch die
vorsorge traurig ich werde einfach an
lava fällst dass wir wirklich das wäre
sehr traurig weil der fall an weil ich
loyal bin ja ich wüsste auch nicht ob
ich das dann allein weitermachen wollen
wir was schon ist schon traurig da ist
dann nur noch alleine aufnehmen das ist
ein bisschen kann also mit tut auch mir
tut auch stehe ich ganz gewaltig leid
dass er hier nehmen hier nicht das hat
er verdient
ja okay stimmt so wie wir in jeder
klasse pvp war
da ist es natürlich habe ich schon
mitgekriegt ich sinnlos mit dem so jetzt
jetzt komme ich wieder nach oben ich
bearbeite weit unten unter berge ich
habe jetzt diesen stein hier mit einer
hand weg weil ich keine spitzhacke habe
wir müssen uns auch darum kümmern dass
wir uns ein
das wird schwierig sich nicht
entscheiden zu machen sondern
verzauberung tisch weil du musst ja
braucht er dafür obsidian und auch
diamanten glaube ich noch mal oder und
diamanten 2 auf jeden fall ich hab's gar
nicht genau im kopf aber ich könnte
jetzt auf meiner tollen kräftig da ist
ein krieger du hast du kräftig ab ich
habe mir warum hast du eigentlich
obenauf gemacht dass ein krieg ja weil
ich doch heute brauche also dann dann
manchmal sind unter den ersten kritiken
bekommen wahrscheinlich auch das segment
monster hunter bitte ich bitte dich
nicht
danke schön dass du gut gemacht ich
hatte hatte schon dezent angst dass du
da die ich vielleicht ein bisschen
überschätzt also eigentlich das
studieren eisenstadt gemacht ich hatte
ja kein holz aber jetzt komme ich klar
an handball was macht ihr mal ein
schwert ich habe hier auch jetzt ich
habe zwölf weise habe ich mitgebracht
von drei davon eine spitzhacke und mit
den restlichen können wir vielleicht
schon mal reicht das für jeden von herrn
das würde glaubt das würde für jeden von
hellem reichen weiß was auch killer welt
finde taktik wenn uns zu einer entgegen
kommt dass wir uns einfach in einen baum
quasi reihen bauen
ich brauche man holz ich gehe mal hoch
kann sie mir holz geben ein bisschen
holz ich habe das selber fast angenehm
eigentlich nix machen kann kann ich
danke ich jetzt bringt die server die
server lex die kam eigentlich nur davon
dass halt die so viele spieler
eigentlich drauf waren haben wir im
nachhinein gemerkt haben wir haben wir
glaube ich im nachhinein gemerkt gab es
eine kleine nachbesprechung du hast
natürlich gleich wieder wieder weg mit
diesen nicht müsste auch weg du das ja
muss schon wieder gas kaufen so wie ich
war aber passend und wir müssen aufhören
geht es ist 14 moment wolle doch so helm
ich habe mal runter ja ich mag mich wie
ich mich über die übertreibt total liebe
müssen aufhören also in dieses nicht
aufhören weil hier geht es ganz schön
schwierig denn solche fahrrad auf jeden
fall reizen dorma und klatschen auf
video
wenn ihr wollt dass ein produktiv sinn
weiterzumachen und sonstig sagen
schreibt uns tipps tricks in die
kommentare schreibt uns was ihr für eine
nationalität zeitung hieß es